Từ đây, tìm, tìm, tìm, tìm.
Tìm. Tìm, tìm.
Tìm.
Xin chào các bạn, tôi và phương anh đã lướng trên, chuyến tổ nghiệt lịch sử.
Trứng kiến, một cái khoảng khách của năm, một chiến năm từ.
Tò ngay một mùi thống, tất nhiên đây là, trúng là,
Tò phục dựng tôi nhá, chứ khỏe đu thật đồ.
Tò thang, có anh đây, dạy có phà nội không mạng.
Có chứ bạng.
Nói, phù hục trưng đây, thà nội, chỉ ước tháng người, nói về ngày một người tháng người năm tư.
Đây là ngày 1 lửa tiếp quản thà nội sau khi nó phải sien,
bằng người ra nổ, số ra được bị trở đó.
Anh ơi, có bạn hỏi là trong anh cứ liệu người ta ăn mặc là cái gì nào?
Ờ, thấy thì có ra thì quần hảo quần lần sau đâu.
Nó làm gì cũng như lửa trọng đâu.
Nhưng mà cái quan trọng là, thì cạo xúc trên vương mặt của mọi người,
ai cũng cứ nước mắt luôn, ai cũng vừa bị.
Mình người ta ở lợt, phải chơi đợi, chứng năm rồi, chứng năm rồi,
lại không thủ đồ, có nước bạn mà người phụ lưu thì đúng với cò này.
Chẻ em thì cô vàng như gần quần này, mình sẽ bạnh thử mình trong răng,
nhưng mình được số mở cái thời đế, mình cũng tốt ngạch nhau theo hết.
Hát sự ước.
Nhưng là RENZI, nhưng lại thấy muốn xem thật sự rồi.
Ờ, em ơi, em phải đến đi, anh nó thật đấy.
Nhưng anh tầm đồ, anh gầy, em sẽ nó thích lắm.
Anh tư liệu đây để liệu dưới được.
Nhưng khi điệu đấy.
Và từng bà để gần có một bộ xíu tập của nhà xíu tập mút tảnh,
có rất nhiều những hiện bật trương nhân hiện tạo.
Quý em, mà một hiện bật ấy lại làm một câu chuyện của một gia đình thàn hội,
nó khiến cho lịch sử, cho đi rất là vụ.
Ờ, tầm bà có phụ học chọt xin khu mặt, sợ cã em không nhiều.
Phụ học lắm, có việc đồng của bố học xin, để tầy hơi hoài, nhau lắm.
Chúng mình nghĩ có con chứng chính hướng rất là cái cho học xin,
với v kẻ chuyện của bố với tình mưa tuổi.
Điều mà hoài ai vào biết ngày dạy phó miền năm là ngày vân yêu thì ăn nhớ.
Hãy biết, nhưng mà hoài đến dạy phóng cửa đô.
Dù bạy phóng biết tờ.
Đúng.
Nhớ nhớ.
Nhớ 1 người tấm 1 người, 1 chiến năm tư.
Hơi thì năm nay 1 người tấm 1 người của năm nay không phải sống này.
Chứ định phải đến bảo tạy hà nước để xe lần ra.
Nhớ đây.
Phó lắm mình, để xe hình yêu xe đi.
Thủ kia hò nhá.
Bye bye.